well it's this is certainly the worst
crisis since the Great Depression so far
now in everyone I in some sense wonders
whether we are headed towards another
Great Depression and no one can answer
that question with certainty it is my
sense that we will that this this crisis
will bottom out before we reach true
1930s level conditions because
governments are more sensitive to the
risk of a Great Depression today than
they were in 1929 1930 and governments
are cooperating more effectively
effectively today than they did in the
1920s and 1930s so I think that that
this is we are unlikely to see or a Pete
of the Great Depression of the 1930s
nonetheless this is unquestionably the
most serious economic downturn economic
crisis of the past 70 or so years what
happens in the longer run cannot with
any certainty before cast however I
think that we can say with the great
degree of certainty that this crisis
will last for fairly long time at least
a couple of years that it will
inevitably involve a substantial series
of austerity measures on the part of
major governments that it will lead to a
reduction in the real living standards
of many many millions and hundreds of
millions and billions of people around
the world that it will slow or even halt
and perhaps even reverse many of the
economic advantages that we have
advances that we have seen over the past
15 or 20 years so this is a serious
crisis this is going to set the world
back a decade or so and perhaps set the
United States back a decade or so as
well we had made some very substantial
improvements in our macroeconomic
position in alleviating some of the the
problems that we had had in the United
States with income distribution in
reducing poverty in the US and much of
that is going to be much of those
advances are going to be called into
question by the current crisis and the
attempts to deal with it in effect
way